let's look at um let's say something
that's Radioactive in a different way
the recent ad campaign about Balenciaga
right so if you're going to have people
talking about the pros and cons of
Balenciaga you can and the ads where
they had those kids with the teddy bears
and bondage and I want to use them words
carefully I can see how a corporation
would be like you know what we're trying
to have a certain image and have a
certain platform and there's certain
things that are going to be uh Beyond
The Pale here and because they have to
be worrying about their advertising I'm
okay with that power of corporate
America is just absolutely enormous I I
there was another story about Balenciaga
they had done similar ad campaigns and
people are saying there's no way that
that slipped like there's no way they
produce an ad and didn't know what they
were producing I I think there's
absolutely a way because this is how
because I think we all we forget how
dumb suits are so all it would take
would be one uh um art director and then
for him to be like look it's already
it's edgy the kids were not being shown
themselves in any kind of provocative or
a state of
undress they were just showing
iconography which is very different from
like Maple Thorp who's at museums where
you're showing full frontal on little
girls which got funding which oh yeah oh
you didn't know without Maple third
thing this oh this oh this is this is
another example of how the corporate
press is just completely dishonest if
you look at articles maplethorpe had
funding from uh um the art the Nea right
the National Endowment for the Arts and
he was this great photographer a lot of
the photography he was taking was very
very transgressive would be like two men
one has a whip somewhere another one was
the razor on his you know what and he
had and then then Jesse Helms with
Center at the time says this is not
where our money should be going to and
he was condemned as homophobic well many
of these images were literally child
pornography there's one of a little girl
with her knee up flashing her genitals
to the camera but if you read any USA
Today Washington Post article it really
just sounds like you've got two guys
kissing and Jesse Helms the homophobe
has a problem with it so it's completely
skewed and just just let me finish so in
terms of Balenciaga if you look at it
you could be like oh it's kids with
teddy bears it's like they're punks you
know you got this badass thing you're
not gonna really read oh here's the
printout of this lawsuit here's what
this book entails so on and so forth I
disagree I don't think it suits missing
it I think the the messaging was clear
there's a history of it and I think
there's a reason Balenciaga deleted
their Instagram deleted their Twitter
because people were picking up on more
and more and more signs there's no way
that you could see that image and be
like yeah it's totally fine totally okay
there's no way it was so blatant it was
so in our face and there was multiple
instances multiple uh multiple times
where it's just extremely Troublesome
and for an executive to look at it and
say oh Teddy Bears BDSM dolls yeah yeah
babies laying down in in precarious ways
oh yeah the tape here or this case
there's no way they missed it I think it
was a deliberate sign to just brag about
what they were doing when you look at
when you look at the Fashion industry
they have a long history of being uh let
me just finish really quickly they have
a long history of have having a lot of
Jeffrey Epstein types Jeffrey Epstein
was all in the future industry and a lot
of the other individuals that were on
that Client List are still in the
fashion industry were never held
responsible for their crimes and whether
it's running Victoria Secret sending out
this messaging this messaging is not
something that is an accident because
they've been doing it for many years
trying to normalize children as models
and a lot of the female models look like
young boys I don't think that's an
accident I think a lot of this is on
purpose because there's a lot of very
dark Sinister people in that industry
that wanted to gloat and highlight how
bad they are and they want to get away
with it and this was this representation
from what I saw I've not disagreeing
with anything you said what I'm saying
is it's not that they missed it it's
that the suit was like this isn't my job
uh you have a photographer that
photographer has a brand name I'm just
the guy the money guy I'm gonna let him
do what he wants it's not my place to
jump and interject and basically in that
industry these people who have brand
names like Balenciaga is a brand name
can basically have free reign to do
whatever the heck they want they spend
millions of dollars on these
I mean the president of the United
States literally decides what kind of
tie he wants to to set a particular mood
to have the particular background
there's no way they're spending millions
of dollars on these fashion shoots and
not micromanaging every little small
animal you're not hearing what I'm
saying what I'm saying is I don't think
it's a suit I think it was deliberately
done and I think the students were
complicit in it okay I I think a lot of
times in big corporations the
responsibility is very much disjointed
and one hand is not knowing what the
other hand is doing and I think the
reason wait hold on the reason why this
social media got pulled is because then
someone realized holy crap
otherwise they would have left it up
because they're like this has been going
on for a long time we got to do an
analysis to figure out when this started
how many of these iterations are there
so you think people were like seeding
this information into the oh they
definitely were it's not even questions
it's it's everywhere in our
entertainment especially if you feel
like at Disney especially if you look at
the subliminal subconscious mind control
which I particularly call it and the
larger kind of degeneracy that is being
pushed on the individuals and even the
corporate media even talking about Minor
attracted persons there's a huge agenda
when it comes to trying to normalize
this kind of debauchery this kind of
horrible behavior that a lot of powerful
people inside of the government were
committing especially when they were
going to that private island and doing
absolutely horrible things to children
that they kidnapped if you look at the
cover of the DVD for The Little Mermaid
if you look at us at the scene in
Aladdin where they're getting married in
the scene in Aladdin the priest is
excited let me just put it that way if
you look at the background of The Little
Mermaid one of the towers looks like a
certain thing of a male anatomy my point
is a lot of times these artists will put
things that the suit will be oblivious
to that's all and that's one example
where you wasn't wasn't there a movie
The Great Mouse detected or something
where there was like an actual they put
like like porn somewhere in it or
something like that people people
chatted this there's a bunch of adult
content and wieners all throughout uh
you know content for for small children
and uh I think when it comes to these
particular cases uh we know so little
because a lot of this is done in secrecy
we shouldn't be excusing it as an
accident we should always with the
absence of evidence when we see very
Sinners to people who have a history of
hurting small children always think the
worst case possible scenario and demand
more evidence and I think excusing
excusing it as all the suits just missed
it is is an instant or element I'm sorry
if I if I got your argument wrong but I
don't I'm saying the suits just missed
it I said in very many cases because how
these people work is they will get
things past the goalie because the
people who are looking don't know what
to look for and are oblivious to it and
in fact the fact that this has been
going up hold on
the fact that this has been going on for
so long and has only been picked up now
speaks to the point that I'm making that
they're very good at getting things on a
subliminal level that people aren't
going to register so if you have
Balenciaga ads and you have literally
tens of thousands of people seeing these
ads and they're only getting picked up
now that just speaks to my point that a
lot of times the money guy or the
accountant or whoever is is kind of
signing off on this they're not going to
always be aware of what they're saying
yeah I I I I don't mind being compared
to Ian I think Ian's great uh but but at
the same time never excuse me I know
never tried to blame something that that
it could be construed as an accident
when it could be malice that's backwards
explain it to him hanlon's razor is the
opposite would prove malice would would
suggest Mouse is right never attribute
to malice that which can be explained by
incompetence yes thank you you said that
a lot better than I but that would imply
that Mouse's argument is is more likely
true I would just say one point on this
I I agree a bit with with you Michael
um and and I'm not trying to argue other
I think someone intentionally did this
and intentionally for a long time no
question and there are people who are
supposed to be Gatekeepers right if
hundreds of thousands or millions of AD
viewers
didn't even notice this
it's possible that The Gatekeepers of
these companies don't notice this stuff
either but someone is intentionally
doing it also if you're looking if you
look at Hollywood history like there
were a lot of gay references that were
meant there for gay audiences whereas
the straight people watching this and
the executives would be completely
oblivious and there's College course
about this where they go back and
deconstruct these old movies the higher
you go up in a lot of these bigger
institutions especially corporations the
more likelihood that there's going to be
a sociopath in them yes so so on that
assessment and in the absence of
evidence I'm going to assume the worst
mainly because I know what they're
capable of and I think we should from a
point of view not excusing their
behavior but at the same time saying hey
they have a long history here let's get
the evidence here because they they
probably are doing some of the most
awful Sinister horrible things that you
can't even fathom and imagine yourself
you're talking to me who are you
perceiving as excusing this Behavior no
no I'm saying the court the the suits
that just were not aware of it but
that's not an excuse that's an
explanation if you are excited if you're
signing off on something that allows
them but that gives them a way to say oh
we just didn't know yes absolutely we
didn't know we just didn't see this
happening I don't want to even give them
that but I I think I think where you and
I disagree let's take away from
Balenciaga is if you look at let's
suppose the Senate right or or
politicians a lot of these people in
power are not very bright and a lot of
times it's their staffs the staffs that
are doing these malevolent things and
are putting things over and the American
people taking things in terms of War so
I that and that's one of the reasons why
I'm so hopeful is because when you look
at the people who tend to be in power
they're really often very unimpressive
yeah I I think they they use that as a
way to cover their larger actions you
think Biden knows what the hell's going
on um absolutely not he's a puppet and I
think there's there's there's bigger
controllers and there's bigger interests
right behind them okay
sorry well it sounds like you guys are
both right it was both malice and
incompetence at some level people were
maliciously putting I say 100 malice I
did it zero encounter I did it I got
away with it and I'll do it again so I
this is interesting conversation I used
to call a minor Attractive people
because I'm like well I want to be
sensitive about these this this whatever
this delusion or whatever now I'm like
okay pedophile but the thing about
pedophile is there's a big difference
between a 20 year old and a 17 year old
hooking up consensually and a 25 year
old and a nine-year-old getting it on
but when the nine-year-old doesn't know
what's happening that's just with all
directions they're both considered
pedophiles no they're not well I mean if
one kid one's a consensual statutory
rape no okay listen Ian there's
something called Romeo and Juliet laws
yes 15 years old or 16 years old
wherever it's not legal in this there's
another word for that I guess I I guess
I don't know whenever you see that word
written on the Internet run away from
the hill exactly you're like it I I get
at that point it's like it doesn't
matter my point is if if two young
people are within three three or four
years of age many states say that's
that's protected depending like I think
in in some of the states they have these
like like 13 is the limit or 14 is the
limit so basically between 14 and 18 are
shielded from these laws or whatever but
it would be like within three years of
like 20. so if you're like a 20 and a 17
year old so like if a 25 year old and a
17 year old consensually were hooking up
it's big difference than a 25 year old
and a nine-year-old no one's a little
green with you so but they're both
called pedophiles that's the problem
with the word it's so charged that if
someone gets statutory rape accusation
and they're 25 and she's 17 or they're
23. 17 and 25 is not a pedophile well a
lot of people I think consider them
because they're considered minors they
consider them pedophiles and that's
dangerous I agree that it's dangerous
but I think there's there was a New York
Times article several years ago when
they were looking at I mean this is
going to be a darker episode than I
expect well why don't we why don't we
get my friend we were talking about yay
politics yeah let's get to the fun stuff
you know the juice uh there was a New
York Times article there where they're
investigating uh child pornography and
according to that piece the whoever the
FBI I guess it was didn't have enough
staff to even handle the infants that
were being in these videos so the amount
of uh um very young uh stuff that's out
there is profoundly disturbing and I was
going to write a book about this I
talked to my agent about it several
years ago and he's like do you really
want to be doing this research and I'm
like yes and there's multiple incidences
of people coming to Big platforms like
Twitter a couple years ago and saying
hey my photos here when I was underage
are being leaked here Twitter's saying
oh yeah yeah we'll do something about it
and then ignoring those people talk
about this screwing them over and then
at the same time now Twitter for the
first time is saying we're going to be
addressing this problem and now the
Apple App Store is going to do is
threatening to cancel them that's
absolutely great this is the one this is
the you got me triggered now okay now
I'm gonna go full Luke Elon Musk uh
Eliza blue if you're out there I think
she's been on the show yeah this has
been her big issue getting a CP off of
Twitter God bless her this is something
that is uh unambiguously a problem
something unambiguously horrific and you
evil period end of story and a lot of
times people who are in as you said were
in these pick like images or videos
would contact Twitter and Twitter shrug
their hands Elon Musk took over and he's
like all right this is going to be like
Priority One like this is a complete
non-starter this has gotta go we could
worry about racism homophobia
transphobia gender pronouns whatever
this is a problem Forbes
who is an agent of the devil wrote a
tweet an article that says Elon Musk has
tried to take on uh Twitter's child
abuse nightmare but according to experts
has only made it worse and they tweet it
nine times I looked up how often Forbes
had mentioned Twitter and children in
the past they've literally never even
used those two words together previously
so now that Elon is trying to do
something about it Forbes has an issue
with it because they don't have an issue
with it they have an issue with Elon
Musk so this speaks to what Luke is
saying how many people there are in
power who do not care about children at
all but who only care about power and
who get off on having power over their
people including young children thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time